you know billy joel is he the guy who
inducted you into the rock and roll hall
of fame
yes did you ask billy to uh introduce
you at the rock roll hall of fame or did
you just sort of evolve or
no i was the right guy to do it yeah it
was the right he was he was the right
idea he asked me to
induct him but i i couldn't you couldn't
no
because why i was on tour i think oh i
see so it didn't work out
yeah are you guys close or are good
friends or uh i have to tell you billy
uh when i had my very first hit record
in i don't know
uh i don't know what year was 70
something
out of the blue the phone rings and it's
him wow i don't know how you got my
number
you know i'm living in like a little
teeny house in bloomington indiana and
obviously the phone rings hey it's billy
joel
right and i'm like yeah right he goes no
no it is says man i love your new single
and it was a very what song was it that
he loved i don't know
you don't remember maybe amy done with
the night but maybe you remember that
because it's like you know
who does that very few people you talk
about a competitive business
very few people call each other and say
hey well done right it it's true
well yeah it it it is and uh
and all he said was i love the song yeah
i love the song and i just want you to
know it yeah
and and and i love hearing it and i wish
you success and what did you say thank
you and
thank you and that and that was it but
you never forget something like that
no you know and i've had i've had other
people call me and
and and i've called other people who do
you call who did you call that you were
so moved by something you heard
and you said you know what i'm going to
do what billy did for me dylan
dylan yeah and he's called me so and and
said
that record sucks john
you